all right well minus what can you say  about your start to uh the air things  monsters and the champions chess tour  season  uh it's been pretty uh bad uh i played  uh  uh a couple of decent games but the rest  of them  have been poor so i need to  i need to do a lot better than that  how are you  feeling physically your your form has it  um we've heard that you've been down  with covet so how has that affected you  no it's been a little bit better uh  today um but  the first couple of days i was um  um i was feeling like i'm okay but i  don't have any energy  and um  which made it kind of hard to um  to to focus uh and to  because like every time i tried to thank  a bundler um  and again it was a little bit better  today but still pretty fun  okay well we